[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marieta Slomka guten Abend nun
soll wohl eine Art heizungsgipfel den
ampelstreit lösen Robert Habeck lädt
dazu in sein Ministerium ein Datum nach
unbekannt fast ist man versucht zu sagen
bringen sie starken Kaffee und ein paar
Stollen mit das könnte wieder mal eine
lange Nacht werden wie viel Porzellan
inzwischen zerschlagen wurde und die man
da überhaupt wieder einen vernünftigen
Arbeitsmodus finden will ist eine der
Fragen die ich vorhin grünen Chef womit
Nuri purgestellt habe zunächst da war
ein Bericht von Daniela Sonntag und
Stefanie Hein aus Thüringen sie haben
bei der Basis von Grünen und FDP gefragt
wie der Berliner Streit dort
wahrgenommen wird
es gibt öko-brause schicke ein
Spielfilme und viele Fragezeichen wie
ist die wärmewende zu schaffen das
wollen die Grünen Basis und Bürgern
heute Abend im thüringischen Ilmenau
erklären der Bedarf groß die
Verunsicherung ist in meinem
Bekanntenkreis ist groß ich habe doch
gar nichts davon der Gaspreis steigt der
Strompreis steigt ob ich jetzt Umriss
oder nicht spielt überhaupt gar keine
Rolle
also die Art und Weise wie das alles
umgesetzt werden soll nicht in Ordnung
also es ist mir einfach zu unausgegoren
und es sind mir zu viel Schnellschüsse
es prasselt auch auf die Thüringer
grünen viel Unmut über einer Debatte
herein die aus dem Ruder gelaufen
scheint hier im Freistaat liegt die
Partei gerade bei 6% in den Umfragen
grüne Politik verkauft sich ohnehin
schlecht und nun der heizstrahlt
wir sind sehr abhängig in den
ostdeutschen Bundesländern auch in
Thüringen von dem was auf Bundesebene
passiert und ja natürlich trifft uns das
härter als die Westdeutschen
Landesverbände dort gibt es einen viel
besseres Jahr viel bessere Wählerbasis
das haben wir im Osten so nicht ein
anderer Stuhlkreis das gleiche Thema bei
der FDP im seniorenfreizeitzentrum
Steglitz gibt sonst Tanztee diesmal Bier
hier diskutiert der Ortsverband über das
heizgesetz
es gibt jetzt schon in den Markt rein
das Thema ist
brandaktuell es erhitzt derzeit die
Gemüter und das auch hier im Saal viele
Vermieter sind gekommen mit vielen
Fragen grün heizen ja schon aber
praktisch wie wenn ich mit die
Möglichkeiten aufzählige Himmel
Fernwärme für mich in Betracht mein
Anruf bei der kameraversorgerin hat
dagegen auf absehbare Zeit nicht
lieferbar dieses Gesetz ist in dieser
Form an der Lebenswirklichkeit der
Menschen vorbei und doch der öffentliche
Streit mit dem grünen Koalitionspartner
finden einige müsste so laut so heftig
nicht sein Kritik auch an der eigenen
Partei und es ist auch nicht der zu uns
zu irgendetwas zwingt oder die Grünen es
sind die Umstände die Klimawende ist so
die FDP hat hier an der Stelle seine
Vertragstreue nicht bewiesen das finde
ich unsäglich
als FDP Mitglied das tut mir weh das
passt nicht zu einer ehrbaren Partei
aber ich bin absolut dafür dieses Gesetz
jetzt umzusetzen und auch mal anzufangen
irgendwann müssen wir mal anfangen mit
an vielen Dingen lieber pragmatisch
statt dogmatisch so wäre es auch den
Thüringer lieber
schwierig ist es natürlich schon wenn
man das Gefühl hat man kommt mit den
Fakten gar nicht mehr durch und die
Debatte ist so aufgeheizt dass es schwer
ist da auch eine Diskussion zu kommen
der Streit ums warme Wohnzimmer sie alle
wollen ihn führen aber lieber weniger
aufgeheizt als derzeit in der Koalition
wir sind der Grünen Bundespolitik
weitergeht darüber wollen wir mit ihrem
Chef um mit nuripur sprechen guten Abend
Herr norri pur schönen guten abendke
wenn man sich mal so die Zitate der
letzten Tage anguckt Wortbruch
Arbeitsverweigerung Christian Lindner
kann ehrlicher Kaufmann mehr da fragt
man sich schon wie bei so viel ja gut
und auch Misstrauen eigentlich noch eine
vernünftige Arbeitsatmosphäre da in
Berlin zustande kommen soll es ist
richtig dass die gesamte Koalition
zurzeit nach außen zu schrill ist wir
müssen uns alle einen eigenen Nasen
jeweils fassen und zurückkommen in den
Arbeitsmodus der uns letztes Jahr auch
so ausgezeichnet hat nämlich Lösungen
liefern und eine darüber wird auch
Vertrauen wieder erwachsen wir haben
sehr viel miteinander durchgemacht in
dieser Koalition in sehr vielen Runden
zusammengesessen und ähm ich finde das
Land durch eine bedrohliche Krise
gebracht gerade durch diese Winter
gerade auch durch die Arbeit von Robert
habe bei dem Energiebereich aber zurzeit
ist es so schrill und das muss aufhören
ist das jetzt so eine Art proaktive
dskalation von ihnen nein es gibt paar
Verwirrungen es gibt ein paar
Irritationen es geht beispielsweise um
die Frage der aufsetzung eines Gesetzes
im Bundestag nämlich das Gebäude
Energiegesetz also
genau und
wir haben miteinander vereinbart dass
wir vor dem Sommer des Gesetz
verabschieden werden im Bundestag und
ich gehe weiterhin davon aus dass es
passiert und wir haben dafür noch ein
paar Wochen Zeit das wird aber schon
schwierig wenn man sieht dass die FDP
sagt da sein unfassbare viele Fehler in
dem Gesetz und sie möchten das
eigentlich grundsätzlich anders haben
ich bleibe bei dem was ich gesagt habe
alle müssen schauen dass sie ihren
tonmäßigen alle müssen schauen dass sie
ein bisschen
ruhiger sind dann werden wir auch in der
Sachlage deutlich besser vorankommen das
ist das Normalste auf der Welt dass er
im Parlament eingesetzt verbessert die
streite rein die Diskussionen in einem
Parlament in der Wesenskern unsere dem
Demokratie und machen auch die Gesetze
besser aber dafür muss das Gesetz
eingebracht werden und ich gehe davon
aus dass es dabei passiert und ich gebe
sehr gerne zu dass auch dieses Gesetz
wie so ziemlich alle anderen Gesetze wie
der Haushalt im Bundestag verändert
werden können und auch soll was ein
Fehler das jetzt auf Teufel komm raus an
den Bundestag geben zu geben zu wollen
obwohl man genau wusste dass einer der
Koalitionspartner das so nicht
akzeptieren wird
offizielle protestnot über den
Kabinettbeschluss sogar quasi angehängt
also es war eigentlich ein Stück weit
absehbar oder zwei Dinge erstens es war
ja nicht auf Teufel komm raus sondern
verabredet und es ist weiterhin
verabredet ich gehe weiterhin davon aus
dass das Gesetz kommt und zwar vor dem
Sommer und es ist das Normalste auf der
Welt dass man ein Gesetz erst einbringt
und dann miteinander überlegt was man
daran verbessern will und verändern will
das zweite ist die Notwendigkeit des
Gesetzes bei aller
Offenheit dafür dass wir das Gesetz auch
ändern dann relevanten Stellen ist mehr
als offensichtlich es geht nicht darum
dass die Leute jetzt ihre
funktionierenden Heizungen abbauen
müssen bitte heizen Sie weiter mit der
Heizung die sie haben die funktioniert
es geht darum dass wir einsteigen in
andere
Treibstoffe die die fossilen werden
jeden Tag teurer und wenn wir nicht
endlich vorsorgen dann werden die Leute
in ganz viele ganz viele Kosten fallen
reinlaufen und das müssen wir vermeiden
diese Leute von von Problemen ist das
was in den letzten Jahren gefehlt hat
das wollen wir ändern auch mit diesem
Gesetz im Moment sind die Leute aber
auch verunsichert durch diese Verbote
die da erstmal auf Sie zukommen man kann
es ja auch anders machen also zum
Beispiel selbst das Potsdam Institut für
immer folgen Forschung dass Ihnen
sicherlich eher wohlgesonnen ist in der
grundsätzlichen Sorge um den Klimawandel
sagten also eigentlich wären so
marktwirtschaftliche Instrumente
Stichwort Emissionshandel besser als
Verbot und und gebotte und da würden sie
sich auch mit der FDP dann doch
eigentlich vielleicht treffen oder ja
aber noch mal diese verbotsgeschichte
das höre ich laufend es gab neulich
unterschiedliche Interviews von Leuten
die gefragt wurden was denn genau
verboten werden soll ich habe es noch
nicht ganz verstanden es geht darum dass
jetzt alles so weiter läuft wie bisher
und wenn eine neue Heizung nicht mehr
funktioniert eine neue eingebaut werden
soll oder komplett neu eingebaut werden
soll weil Neubau dann geht es darum dass
bis zu 65 Prozent des Treibstoffs
erneuerbare sind ich will mal ein
Beispiel sagen wenn das mal Auslaufen
muss bei Ölheizungen hat die Merkel
Regierung beschlossen dass man sie nur
bis 26 laufen lassen kann und danach
neue kommen müssen es geht darum dass
wir anfangen mit dem Umbau es geht darum
dass wir den Leuten sehr klar und
deutlich rein Wein einschenken und der
heißt es wird teuerer hütet euch und
bereitet euch darauf vor es gibt halt
auch einfach auch viele technische
Fragen die sich den Leuten stellen also
auch Leuten die Ihnen wirklich immer
wohlgesonnen sind zum Beispiel der grüne
Ministerpräsident von Baden-Württemberg
herr Kretschmann sagt besser nicht etwas
in Gang setzen dass ich dann später als
schwerpraktikabel erweist vielleicht
dann doch noch mal tief Luft holen und
überlegen ob man noch mal zurück auf
losgeht der Satz von Winfried
Kretschmann ist ja völlig richtig und
der bezieht sich auf die Frage wann denn
eigentlich das Gesetz in Kraft treten
soll ob am ersten ersten 24 oder später
da gibt es verschiedene Varianten die
möglich sind es ist auch möglich dass
darüber nachgedacht wird ob Öl und
Gasheizung zum Beispiel unterschiedlich
behandelt werden das werden wir im
parlamentarischen Verfahren miteinander
vereinbaren und natürlich gehört auch
dazu dass man Expertin Experten zusammen
holt ihre Meinung in das Gesetz
einfließen lässt ich will nur vor einem
warnen äh das Argument was sie gerade
gebracht haben nämlich dass der Markt
ist ja am Ende Regeln wird ist genau die
Kostenfalle die ich gemeint habe es wird
teuerer werden der Emissionshandel in
Europa wird Öl und Gas deutlich teurer
machen und deshalb werden alle die jetzt
neu bauen beispielsweise sich genau
überlegen müssen was auf lange Sicht
sich rentiert und die Preise werden
irgendwann mal nicht mehr haltbar sein
und deshalb ist es notwendig jetzt noch
anzufangen auch mit einem sozialen
Ausgleich und dabei dürfen wir niemand
zurücklassen
bei einem Streit Polemik und
begleitender medialer Kampagnen die sich
gerade beobachten lassen noch sind wir
hierzulande nicht bei dem Maß an
Polarisierung angelangt wie sie seit
langem in den USA zu beobachten ist wo
gesellschaftspolitische Gräben
unüberwindlich tief geworden sind Donald
Trump hatte das mit einer solchen
Ruchlosigkeit vorangetrieben dass seine
Anhänger ja selbst Wahlergebnisse nicht
mehr anerkennen nun geht es an die
nächste Präsidentschaftswahl eine
Rückkehr von Trump ist nicht
ausgeschlossen allerdings hat er in den
eigenen Reihen Konkurrenz bekommen der
Gouverneur von Florida ronde Santes hat
seinen Hut in den Ring geworfen immer
diese sind berichtet aus den USA
eine Maus genauer diese war bisher ronde
Santes größter Gegner sich mit einem
Konzern wie Disney anzulegen ist für
einen Republikaner mutig aber dazu
gleich mehr denn jetzt tritt die Santes
gegen einen noch größeren Gegner an
Donald Trump deshalb wollte er unbedingt
maximale Reichweite auf Twitter und dann
das
wandelboss Elon Musk ratlos technische
Probleme
sie überschatten alles was er später
sagt und sorgen für Häme ein voran von
Donald Trump der disantis Wahlkampf
Rakete crashen lässt
Mitleid selbst vom Ex Gouverneur von
arcenza der auch für die Republikaner
antritt
das war kein guter erster Eindruck das
soll ja reibungslos laufen und man will
seine Botschaft loswerden aber die ist
in den Pannen untergegangen ich fühle
mit gouverneur de Santes
dabei will er doch den Menschen sagen
dass er anders als Trump gewinnen kann
fast 60% bei seiner Wiederwahl im
letzten Jahr dass er anders als Trump
systematisch erzkonservative Politik
durchzieht er hat die Todesstrafe
erleichtert das Waffenrecht gelockert
Abtreibung nach der sechsten Woche
verboten die Themen sexuelle
Orientierung und Rassismus in Schulen
für Tabu erklärt und er werde als
Präsident die woke Ideologie in den
Mülleimer der Geschichte werfen
genau deshalb Beschnitt er auch Disneys
Sonderrechte in Florida denn der Konzern
hatte seine Politik kritisiert das gilt
vielen Republikanern als zu
wirtschaftsfeindlich
kein Wunder dass er im Kampf gegen Trump
weiter so hoffnungslos zurückliegt auch
die Basis tut sich schwer mit ronde
Santes oder mehr noch er mit ihr denn
seine Reden sind gespickt mit
Fachausdrücken rechts Begriffen ein
fremdeln mit den Wählern dass ihm Trumps
Spot einträgt
eine persönlichkeitstransplantation aber
die gibt es noch nicht
er mag Menschen nicht redet nicht gern
mit ihnen will nicht mit ihnen zusammen
sein und dann noch das Debakel letzte
Nacht daraus zu kommen wird schwierig
es wird wohl an die Santes hängen
bleiben dass er mit einem Superreichen
Narzissten statt vorjubelnden Fans seine
Kandidatur bekannt gab und dann auch
noch ohne dass man ihn dabei sehen
konnte
was für ein unglaublich schlechtes
Urteilsvermögen wer will schon
unsichtbar sein wenn er Präsident werden
will es ist wichtig wie dich die
Menschen sehen
wenn die Santes ernsthaft sein größter
Gegner werden will sagen manche muss er
nicht nur Trump besiegen sondern lernen
wie man Wahlkampf richtig inszeniert
bei dir geht es jetzt weiterhin zunächst
mit dem Blick in die Ukraine ja die Lage
in der schwer umkämpften Stadt bachmut
ist weiter unklar die russische Seite
hatte die komplette Einnahme der Stadt
verkündet die Ukraine sprach dagegen von
andauernden Gefechten und währenddessen
hat die Söldnergruppe Wagner nach
Angaben ihres Chefs Perry Goshi mit dem
Abzug der eigenen Truppen aus Bach Mut
begonnen bis zum 1 Juni solle die Stadt
komplett den regulären russischen
Streitkräften zur Kontrolle überlassen
werden sagte in einem heute
veröffentlichten Video
Iran hat eine neue ballistische
Mittelstrecke Rakete vorgestellt
Verteidigungsminister astiani sagte die
Rakete können bin in kurzer Zeit für den
Start vorbereitet werden unser in der
Lage sich der radarerfassung zu
entziehen nach offiziellen Angaben hat
die Rakete eine Reichweite von 2000 km
damit wäre sie grundsätzlich in der Lage
Ziele in Israel zu erreichen der Westen
sieht im iranischen Militär und
Raketenprogramm eine Gefahr für den
Nahen Osten und die Golfregion
die Eisenbahn und Verkehrsgewerkschaft
IVG hat im Tarifstreit mit der Deutschen
Bahn weitere Warnstreiks für die
nächsten Tage vorerst ausgeschlossen die
Bahn habe heute ein neues Angebot
vorgelegt dass man nun prüfen werde so
die EVG ziel sei es die
Tarifverhandlungen bereits in der
kommenden Woche vorzusetzen
Arbeitskämpfe können wir bis dahin
ausschließen teilte die EVG weiter mit
die Lufthansa Group hat sich mit der
italienischen Regierung über einen
Einstieg bei der Fluggesellschaft ita
Airways geeinigt zunächst mit einer
Minderheitsbeteiligung im Rahmen einer
Kapitalerhöhung erwirbt die Lufthansa
41% der bisher verlustreichen Alitalia
Nachfolgerin und zahlt dafür 325
Millionen Euro die Vereinbarung sieht
außerdem vor dass Lufthansa die Anteile
erhöhen oder hinter Airways vollständig
übernehmen kann
im sächsischen Freiberg haben forschende
in einer Versuchsanlage 15.000 Liter
synthetisches Benzin hergestellt bis
2026 soll ein knapp 400.000 Liter
erzeugt werden
Verkehrsminister Wissing und
Ministerpräsident Kretschmer
informierten sich vor Ort über das
Projekt das staatlich gefördert wird
ziel ist es die Produktion von efuels
effizienter und damit preiswerter zu
machen welche Rolle die sogenannten
Zukunft tatsächlich spielen werden ist
allerdings umstritten
die Hausdurchsuchungen bei der letzten
Generation und das Abschalten Ihrer
Webseite haben hier eine ziemliche
Debatte ausgelöst die einen halten es
für unklug diese Bewegung derart hart
anzugehen das führe eher zu
Radikalisierung als zu Disziplinierung
zumal die Gruppe bis langsam mit ihren
Aktionen viele extrem nervt aber in
ihrem konkreten Forderungen alles andere
als extremistisch ist Tempo 100 und 9 €
Ticket damit wird ja nun wahrlich nicht
der Verfassungs startet Frage gestellt
dem gegenüber stehen jene die sagen nee
das reicht jetzt mal oder wie ist die
bundesinnenministerin formulierte der
Rechtsstaat lässt sich nicht auf der
Nase herumtanzen
allerdings sollte sich der Staat auch
der Freistaat Bayern dabei selbst an
rechtsstaatliche Regeln halten mehr dazu
von Sarah Tacke
sie stören sie beschmieren
sie blockieren
entnervt wütend aufgebracht sind die die
sie damit treffen und gestern dann
reagiert auch der Rechtsstaat jedenfalls
der bayerische bundesweite Razzien
veranlasst von der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München ihr
Verdacht die letzte Generation könnte
eine kriminelle Vereinigung sein bislang
haben sie nicht mehr als diesen Verdacht
schreibt man aber trotzdem auf die
beschlagnahmte Internetseite der letzten
Generation die letzte Generation stellt
eine kriminelle Vereinigung gemäß
Paragraph 129 Strafgesetzbuch da
Ausrufezeichen als sei das schon
richterlich entschieden wenn eine
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft sagt hier
handelt es sich um eine kriminelle
Vereinigung am Beginn eines
Ermittlungsverfahrens ist das eine
Vorverurteilung die der
Unschuldsvermutung die
selbstverständlich auch in diesem Falle
gilt hohen spricht und das darf nicht
sein
eine klare rechtswidrige Vorverurteilung
und das durch Staatsanwälte die es
besser wissen müssten wieso geht die
bayerische Justiz so hart gegen
klimaaktivisten vor natürlich kann man
nicht übersehen dass solche Ermittlungen
Einfluss auf den heraufziehenden
bayerischen Wahlkampf haben ihr wird
versucht politischen Aktivismus mit
juristischem Aktionismus zu beantworten
und die Verhältnismäßigkeit bleibt auf
der Strecke
die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München
sagt zur rechtswidrigen Vorverurteilung
auf zdf-nachfrage heute aufgrund der
Missverständlichkeit wurde der Hinweis
zeitnah gestrichen nur eine
Missverständlichkeit oder schlägt der
Rechtsstaat hier bewusst härter zu als
er darf
das über harte justizielle Vorgehen
setzt eine
Eskalationsspirale in Gang weil sich die
Aktivisten in die Enge getrieben fühlen
könnten ich glaube dass jetzt der Weg
zurück gefunden werden muss in die
Verhältnismäßigkeit und zwar auf beiden
Seiten denn sonst kann eine wirklich
verhängnisvolle gesellschaftliche
Entwicklung in Gang gesetzt werden
Spirale hat längst begonnen sich zu
drehen nach den Razzien gestern
verkündet die letzte Generation heute
sie sei jetzt stärker als je zuvor und
will die Proteste noch ausweiten und
übers Klima spricht aktuell kaum noch
einer
das wofür Protestbewegungen wie die
letzte Generation oder Fridays for
future kämpfen ist sehr
interessanterweise nicht etwas was die
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft ablehnt im
Gegenteil Klimaschutz ist quasi
Mainstream bis auf die AFD bekennen sich
auch alle im Bundestag vertretenen
Parteien dazu gestritten wird über
Dringlichkeit und Instrumente hinzu
kommt das sogenannte nimbi-phänomene der
Bevölkerung Nord in my backyard
Klimaschutz ja aber bitte nicht in
meinem Vorgarten die FDP etwa hat jene
autofahrenden Wähler im Blick die an
ihrem Verbrenner hängen die Suche nach
geeigneten e-fuels soll einen Ausweg
bieten ein Hoffnungsträger in diesem
Bereich ist HvO was ist damit auf sich
hat erklärt Julian Schmidt
Frittenfett solche abfallöle könnten die
deutschen Straßen nachhaltiger machen
glaubt Nico ziegemeier hier an seiner
Tankstelle bietet er schon vor der
flächendeckenden Zulassung den dieser
Ersatz HvO an HvO wie Hydro treated
vegetables hydrierte Pflanzenöle und
andere Abfallprodukte die zu
spritverarbeitet werden und so im
Vergleich zum fossilen Diesel bis zu 90%
co2-sparen sollen der Markt kommt jetzt
immer mehr bei dir Leute einfach hier in
herkömmlichen Dieselmotor auch je
älteres Fahrzeug die wollen nicht
umsteigen auch neue E-Autos z.B die
wollen ihr Diesel CO2 neutral betreiben
und einfach damit fahren und die Autos
länger damit nutzen ähnlich wie Bio
Diesel wird HvO bislang dem fossilen
Sprit nur beigemischt die
Bundesregierung wird das auf Druck des
Verkehrsministeriums ändern künftig soll
der dieser Ersatz zu 100% im tanklanden
dürfen
der ADAC hat den Kraftstoff geprüft das
Ergebnis neben dem co2-vorteil stößt ein
hvo-wagen auch weniger andere
Schadstoffe aus nur herstellungsbedingt
ist HvO bislang teurer als diese da muss
man sehen wo die Reise hingeht wenn
natürlich dieser Kraftstoff dann mehr
und in größerem Umfang produziert wird
kann es durchaus sein dass ich die
Kosten hier anpassen in Schweden zum
Beispiel gibt es den ökosport bereits
seit 8 Jahren an den Tankstellen HvO
kostet dort rund 50 Cent mehr pro Liter
als Diesel und verharrt mit seinem
Marktanteil noch immer unter
5%. hierzulande kritisieren
Umweltministerium und Umweltbundesamt
mit HvO sei dem Klima womöglich kaum
geholfen der Grund auch Abfall ist knapp
die Ausgangsstoffe für den dieser
Ersatz-
nicht nachhaltigere Optionen oder gar
fossile
Ausgangsprodukte gesetzt werden muss
auch die mineralindustrie sagt absehbar
gibt es nicht genug HvO für jeden Diesel
der Bundesverkehrsminister will trotzdem
an der grünen alternative festhalten das
Argument man kann mit HvO nicht alle
betreiben ist nicht überzeugend denn
jedes Fahrzeug das mit HvO betrieben
wird und damit weniger CO2 imitiert
leistet einen Beitrag zum Klimaschutz
manche Busse und sogar Züge wie hier in
München fahren schon heute mit HvO auch
einzelne LKW für Autofahrer soll der
diese Ersatz noch in diesem Jahr kommen
und klar bleibt wie teuer ist wird und
welchen Beitrag HvO wirklich zur
Verkehrswende leistet
was die Energiewende auch nicht leichter
macht dass sie in einer Zeit
wirtschaftlichen Abschwungs
vorangetrieben wird Heinz da gab es
heute keine guten Nachrichten von der
Konjunkturlage ja nach neuen Daten der
Statistischen Bundesamtes ist die
deutsche Wirtschaftsleistung im ersten
Quartal dieses Jahres erneut geschrumpft
um 0,3% gegenüber dem Vorquartal in dem
es auch schon ein Minus gegeben hatte
und bei zweimal minus hintereinander
sprechen Ökonomen von einer technischen
Rezession von Bethmann was sind die
Gründe für diese Entwicklung ja ein
Grund die Teuerung die hat auch in den
letzten Monaten die Preise weiter
getrieben die Menschen konnten sich
weniger von dem teuren leisten mit
anderen Worten es wurde weniger gekauft
um die Preise einzufangen erhöht die
Europäische Zentralbank die Leitzinsen
was wiederum die Wirtschaft nicht
besonders toll findet dann steigende
Zinsen bedeuten Kredite werden teurer
und so überlegen inzwischen immer mehr
Betriebe ob wirklich jede Investition
die man eigentlich tätigen wollte noch
sinnvoll ist also weniger Investitionen
gut weniger Konsum das bremst dann eben
die Wirtschaftskraft ein vom rückblick
zum Ausblick wie sind die Erwartungen
wie es weitergeht abgesehen von
einzelnen Lichtblicken wie zum Beispiel
im Dienstleistungsgewerbe wo es besser
läuft insgesamt eher düster der
Schrumpfkurs der deutschen Wirtschaft
werde sich im zweiten Halbjahr
fortsetzen so die meisten Ökonomen
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck sprach heute
davon dass in Deutschland bis zu 60
Milliarden Euro zu wenig investiert
würden wegen der steigenden Zinsen wegen
der Inflation aber auch weil Deutschland
strukturelle Probleme habe eine älter
werdende Gesellschaft zu viel Bürokratie
viel zu wenig Fachkräfte habe ich
wirklich wir müssen eine Trendumkehr
schaffen gegenwärtig aber ist nicht
absehbar wann das gelingen könnte Frank
Bethmann vielen Dank
beim Spiegel gibt es einen Wechsel in
der Chefredaktion Steffen Klußmann
verlasse die Chefredaktion nach der
Umsetzung weitreichender Reformen in den
vergangenen Jahren im gegenseitigen
Einvernehmen teilte das Medienhaus mit
es übernimmt dem nach der Spiegel Autor
und ehemalige stellvertretende
Chefredakteur Dirk kobeweis
zum Sport bei der Tischtennis WM in
Südafrika haben im Doppel Dimitri
ofterov und Patrick Franziska eine
Medaille sicher durch einen Sieg im
Viertelfinale heute ob es mehr wird als
Bronze entscheidet sich dann morgen im
Halbfinale gegen die Vize-Weltmeister
young boy Yin und YUM YUM aus Südkorea
nicht sicher aber möglich ist eine
Medaille für das deutsche Eishockey Team
bei der WM in Finnland und Lettland die
Mannschaft steht im Halbfinale wie
zuletzt auch schon vor zwei Jahren
wieder passiert in Lettlands Hauptstadt
Riga wieder ein viertelfinal-sieg und
wieder ist es nichts für schwache Nerven
gegen die Favoriten aus der Schweiz beim
1:08 Minuten durch Maximilian Kastner
ist Glück dabei Robert Meier lässt den
harmlosen Schuss ins Tor Rollen den
Ausgleich konnte das Team im zweiten
Drittel innerhalb von einer Minute per
Doppelschlag durch die NHL Profis John
Peter und Nico Sturm der zum 3:1
entstand trifft und das in Unterzahl da
waren die deutschen Stadt wir waren gut
gut vorbereitet auf alles was davon die
Jungs wo wir die 5 Minuten Strafe
Kriegen des Unterzahl was die Jungs da
gemacht haben war wirklich einzigartig
und ja es ist einfach unglaublich dass
wir dabei sind schon meine Situation und
wir sind wir sind hungrig auf mehr auf
jeden Fall wir wollen wir wollen auf
jeden Fall eine Medaille holen die
deutsche Mannschaft steht damit nicht
nur im WM Halbfinale am Samstag sondern
ist auch für Olympia in drei Jahren
qualifiziert
das war es im heute schon mal gleich
geht es bei Maybrit Illner weiter die
mit ihren Gästen über die Lage in der
Ukraine spricht mitten der Runde sitzen
unter anderem Sigmar Gabriel und Carlo
Masala und um 0:35 Uhr gibt es dann
unsere heutigen Update mit Christopher
Wehrmann und hier erwarten Sie morgen
Dunja Hayali und Gundula Gause schönen
Abend noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Temperaturen
über Mitteleuropa liegen um die 20 Grad
Marke aber bereits im Norden
Deutschlands ist es spürbar Kühler das
liegt an der Lage des Hochs über den
britischen Inseln auf seiner Ostseite
kommt diese kühlere Luft vor allem in
den Norden Deutschlands das ändert sich
aber in den nächsten Tagen es wird
allmählich wärmer auch im Norden schauen
wir auf die Details in der Nacht gibt's
im Süden Wolken auch nach ostenden oder
Richtung Nordsee sonst Klatte auf und es
bildet sich teilweise Nebel bei tiefsten
Temperaturen im Westen um die drei Grad
ansonsten 12 Grad in Bayern das ist die
Temperatur Spanne morgen dann viel
Sonnenschein in der Mitte und auch im
Osten Deutschlands nach Westen in einige
Wolken auch im Norden und auch im Süden
das bei Temperaturen bis 13 Grad im
Nordwesten und 16 Grad Richtung Ostsee
deutlich kühler als im Süden
Deutschlands hier 21 bis teils 24 Grad
Richtung Oberrhein die nächsten Tage
gehen trocken und überwiegend sonnig
weiter 14 bis 26 Grad am Samstag ja und
Pfingstsonntag geht schon auf 27 Grad
und auch im Norden wird es etwas wärmer
Pfingstmontag ähnlich die Werte bei viel
Sonnenschein mit 14 bis 26 Grad und
damit ein schöner Abend